okay I'm gonna go play Knight C6 I mean
I prepared this a lot for Canty we
played into this a few times
here we have a Spanish Spanish Exchange
D4
I haven't played one of these in a long
time
I'm pretty sure C5 is a move which is
proof basically force a queen drain
and we're getting this pretty iconic
structure
pretty iconic imbalance
where black has double pawns on the
queen side
but at the same time I have the bishop
pair
now what I could do is trade off this
bishop and double White's Pawns
which I'm kind of liking because I like
Castle Queen side with tempo
and then if Bishop D2 or Knight D2 I can
play Knight H6
and I just win the pawn G4 is prevented
I think I'll do that
the alternative was G6 which I'm sure is
playable but this just seems very simple
to play
and now this move and yeah White's a bit
stuck because Knight's pinned
and it blocks in the bishop and I win
upon
and now this move
and Black's winning more material wow
yeah this is kind of crumbling quickly
for whites this is double check
always look for a stronger
but this is pretty strong
I might lose back the knights
oh there's a funny line
it's hard to make it work though unless
I can make it work
always play F6
expecting the bishop to move
I'm threatening Maiden one
the night is useful on A1 it controls B3
and I think this is made in two look at
this move B4
cing this
the Knight is actually so pivotal Here
and Now Rook D4 checkmates
it's amazing how many things work
together for the mates
the pawns The Rook the bishop defends E5
the Knight controls B3 and the clutch A6
Pawn
oh no my keyboard
I'll plug in my keyboard
uh yeah that was a reason to play Asics
on
move three
I had to foresee that the King was gonna
come to C4 I had to control the B5
Square
yeah probably not the best game for my
opponent but uh
perhaps a valuable lesson to take away
is that even when Queens are traded and
position simplifies you still really
have to be careful about King safety
and just holding on to the position I
think the best move here is King E2 but
like it's already
difficult for lights
um I think
oh Knight takes D4 is already a mistake
yeah Queen D4 is the main line
I guess the problem with Knight T4 is
this uh the C5 move and black gains a
lot of time
okay I hope that game inspires some
people